open the curtains
so
so show them where your oxygen is
when alex was born his mom was told he
wouldn't live beyond a week
he is now a thriving 16 year old but
needs near constant support
at night an oxygen machine keeps him
alive
during the day a pump provides vital
food water and medicine
just let me swap your feed round please
first
everything is run off batteries and
mains power
bills just go up and up i would probably
say an extra 300 pound a month
just in
in household bills and things for alex
it's a case of life and death obviously
because he's on his oxygen machine
overnight so
if we couldn't
literally afford
to pay those bills then
i don't know what would happen
this is the stark situation faced by
families with sick and disabled children
at home as energy prices rise they
simply can't unplug it worries me for
the future as to
if things do get worse
how
how will it affect us as a family um
what what do we do kind of thing because
it's all very well and good somebody
coming and saying go and get an extra
job or do this and do that but alex
alone is a full-time job i feel like
it's a constant battle with a child with
a disability
and it never stops
a battle in in what sense
sorry that's okay
it's incredibly hard
sorry
much needed respite comes from here this
centre was set up by emma and other
local parents it's been entirely built
and funded by the community it's support
at the end of the day and there's not
much of it around
you know at the minute it doesn't do me
any good staying on the outside
hearing me all the time
even though i didn't love you very much
still not gonna do any good
these children and their families dearly
need this help
they worry as prices rise and budgets
tighten it will become harder to find
sky news in wigan